most couples therapy is useless not
because the therapy is wrong but because
most couples don't go to therapy
together until one of them is absolutely
not wanting to work on the relationship
anymore they're using therapy as an
excuse to air their frustration one last
time
so many times I've had couples come in
and that's exactly what it is is one is
all in for it and is convinced I'm going
to fix their partner and tell them that
they've been right all along and the
other partner comes in dreading it
because their partner's the one who set
it up and they say what and what sort of
Buzz saw am I walking into it is a
miserable experience for all three
people involved unless I can turn them
around and convince the other partner
that I'm there to help them in which
case the first partner can is convinced
that I have somehow pulled a Switcheroo
and they are now going to get betrayed
by their by their coach now who's
working with them it's an ugly process
it is really ugly the only time couples
therapy really works is when they are
coming in because they both want to make
it work but they don't have the skills
and they have no idea what to do if they
both want to make it work it's an
amazing experience